now everybody we just got out of the
scene avatar The Wave water and what a
real thing what do you all think um
okay initial reactions Go I mean
visually stunning I didn't think I was
going to be crying but they got me they
got me yeah I love the relationships and
I love the story all right perfect Tessa
yeah the story was great I think it's
absolutely gorgeous that's the main
takeaway here is that you should really
see it in like IMAX 3D that's what the
way it was made to be seen
hours one through three were amazing
hours four through six though eight one
through three uh I was glad I was
wearing 3D glasses because you couldn't
see when I cried it was very good though
very happy always like it cut every time
you felt like it was wrapping up it
jumped into another segment which to me
is like a perfect Action Movie awesome
believe the hype get wet this winter at
the movies James camera knows how to use
one
it's good most importantly Ivy had some
really great things to say about it
absolutely
all right you heard it there first
stunning I guess I can't film like this
stunning perfect and thank you to
everybody for being his video
it's all gonna make the final cut and so
I'll make the final cut perfectly